[Musique]
le piano en fait c'est ma maman qui
avait acheté un petit un petit piano
Roland un petit clavier numérique et du
coup
elle achète le piano personne vous dans
la maison donc je me mets un petit peu à
deux si quand je suis petit il y a un
truc qui se passe ça vibrant en moi la
musique le piano c'est un moyen de
m'exprimer de d'exprimer mes émotions de
vraiment communiquer aussi le partage
avec les autres et je pense que c'est le
plus important pour moi c'est ça
les concours ouais c'est une nouvelle
expérience pour moi j'en ai gagné pas
mal c'est vrai sur les cinq continents
donc ouais c'est vraiment
l'occasion de de pousser ses limites moi
j'aime ça pousser mes limites autant
dans la technique dans la créativité
[Musique]
ma musique ma musique elle est très
improvisée très libre parce que je suis
comme ça je joue un peu comme je suis
c'est développé un miroir entre ma
personnalité et la musique
l'album il s'appelle life Town white one
kiss and black case
ce qui veut dire un peu
pour moi le la vie
à travers des touches blancs et noir ça
parle un peu de la résilience côté
comment surmonter les traumatismes
on le portrait musical ouais c'est un
concept que j'ai développé en plein
covid parce qu'on pouvait plus faire de
concert donc je me suis dit comment
faire pour rester en contact avec les
gens
et je me suis dit autant aller
directement composée la musique des
personnes donc jouer la musique de
quelqu'un dégage et c'est des
expériences incroyables beaucoup
d'émotion j'en fais aussi sur scène que
je prends des personnes aux heures du
public que j'invite à côté de moi et que
je regarde et je joue permet d'être
vachement dans le partage et aussi
l'ouverture à l'autre
[Musique]